earlier we reported on the airline
industries response to the corona virus
joining us now is brian kelly CEO and
founder of the points guy to look at how
changes in the air could affect your
future travel prem plans brian good
morning welcome we just heard the CEO of
Southwest say to Chris Van Cleve that
it's safe to travel when do you think
people will actually believe that it's
safe to travel I think people will
believe it's safe to travel when we've
got testing down and therapeutics and we
are far from that so we sought the
points guy recommend that if you don't
absolutely need to travel you probably
shouldn't at least not on an airplane
now road trips that's a different story
but I think the airlines are in such a
state of you know everything changing do
they require passengers wear masks some
do some don't I still think it's safe to
wait until there's clear standards
across the board if Brian if someone has
to fly and peep some people are in that
situation right now what do you
recommend that they do I recommend you
know most airlines right now in the
month of May or blocking the middle seat
for social distancing although there
have been some reports of that not
happening I recommend booking booked a
window seat because there's less chance
of you being around someone else bring
your own disinfectant wipes wipe down
your seat wear a mask from start to
finish and bring your own food and drink
on the plane the less interaction you
have with other people including flight
attendants the safer you are
there are a lot of people who had trips
booked and now canceling them can they
get their money back what do they do to
get their money back here's the tip to
get your money back you need to wait for
the airline to cancel your flight
if so the Department of Transportation
has ruled that they should give your
money back now some care lines are being
sneaky little devils about it and making
it really hard for consumers to get the
cash back they're gonna automatically
say sure take a voucher but what you
should do as a consumer say I want my
cash because last night check you can't
pay rent with an airline voucher so push
for cash and if the airline hasn't
changed it yet wait because these
airline schedules are changing by the
day so don't
preemptively cancel and get a voucher
when you could wait and get cold hard
cash
Bryant we've seen reports we've been
reporting that that some Cruise Lines
are getting ready to get up and running
again do you think people are gonna be
prepared for that to happen and don't
want to go on cruise ships we were
talking about this yesterday I mean are
people really gonna want to get on
cruises right now I think they will for
a couple reasons number one cruisers are
the most loyal type of travelers I mean
people who love cruising love it and
they generally in general travelers have
short memories and I think if the
cruises can get testing right where they
have accurate quick testing when you
board the ship every evening or morning
and they can track and make sure that
that environment is virus free then all
of a sudden you've got the safe
environment where you can go to the
casino go to a spa do all the things you
can't do on land at least not until we
have a vaccine so if the cruises get
together the testing and safety and
cleaning I think they could be a boon
for travelers interesting for those of
us who are itching to explore but an are
stuck inside is there a way to travel
virtually you know there are a lot of
most destinations now are doing virtual
tours and museums personally that's not
exactly for me it's not quite like going
there but there's tons of places to go
and also you know once things start
relaxing there are so many amazing
places in our own back doors so I highly
recommend this summer plan domestic
trips road trips although be aware not
every state is gonna want us just this
week Maine announced basically we don't
want visitors and if you do come you
have to quarantine for 14 days so I
don't expect most states will have those
rules but it's something to keep an eye
on yeah I've developed a new love affair
with Central Park which I've known for
years but have explored in ways I never
looked at it before and it's like three
blocks from me so there's a way to find
adventure not far from home Brian Kelley
thank you very much